I AMIC HERE INUKRAIN
T BEEN LEVELED, N
.
TENSE
RTKYIV.EA NEW
YOU CAN SEE
D RO  WHPLUMES OF E
ONSLAUGHT.F ERNCREMAG UPAMIDENTN
WITHS VIOLATINHE
E
IAFORCES,RELEASINTHIS VIDEOOF TE
THFINGD AIRCRAFT,THEY SHOT D
A RUSSIAN RCA FIGHTEJET, UKRAINE
BILLOWIN THE WAKE, AND THE
THEY CONTINUE TO FIGHT WITHRNSEY
LIMITED HELP FROWESTERN
AL
WITH UYM ZELENSKYY,
AN
E IS A T FTS FROM EASTEU THE
ESBL ATH IA OU W IIST  FARTHEY'A
VLADIMIR TILACOUN OR GA, OR
IMEN A THAT
AS UKRAINE PFOR RE AND THEY'RE Y
R  RHEW ON I TA DECLARATION
SOLIDARITY FOR THE U.S
THEY AREID
N MINISTER OTHE POLISH BORTHPRI.
NS.RAE P MINISYLENALSPEA A
R A FACE TFACE MEETI PUTIN ME, N
L, WARNING
TBOVINE CIES INTO
ON.
FY, S A TDE 1000 MORE
H  ITS TENTH
CEF RUSSIANKRAINIA
ESSION, NTINUES TO
VEHICLE,N JUMPONOP
NGAI FLAG. T SOUNDAND
IN NORTHEASTERN UKRAINE,ND
GROUND
CRT INN THE
THE STREET
>>THER VERNE FIRE BROKE OUAI
WITH CIVILIAALTIES IG  331
WOUNDED.EEN KI
'RELY TOERS, RUSE AND CNN'SSS
WAS IN PIN ROM
SUBURB BEEN PUMMELY
RUWEE  IE
, , D  SOLERS, HELMFLEE.
THISDGY TH
T IS YET HDLE
MUST BE CROSSED.
AS BEE
BARYS
A NEENOFJUST DPEG TO
SLS
INJU JF HOUREAR.
ILL , THEYING
UNAIDEOTHERS NEED MOREISNC
SOLD MAKESHIFTSTRETCHEO MEAL.
THRENG
CIVILIANS.
, TELLDIFFERY.PSERE TH
INCLUDING UING OUT
R .CLY COSIATR >>BVUS,INCRED, A
TUATION.THD,ETEE.
>> TLEE BE WR
Y.EN THEY WILL
RERN
SHE HAT?MPLETEERWHELME
THIS IS JUST ONE SUBURB IN ONE
DOKNOW WHERE SHE'S GLAUGHTLL
E SAYS.IRPIN FOR 4 W S
AT AREHEACHIEVE?
TONE?BU A ALL ODDS TEN DAYS
INTO THIS WAR, UKRST.S D,
[SPEAKING FOREI LE]
E WILL
IRN,Y THEY